في هذا المكان تحديدا
تواجدت قبل ساعات في وتحدثت مع القائم
بالاعمال السعودي في تركيا الذي قال بانه
تم اجلاء ما يقارب خمسه واربعين مواطن
ومواطنه سعوديين في هذا المكان تحديدا في
هذا الفندق بعد ان كانوا متواجدين في
اماكن متفرقه في ضربها هذا الزلزال بعض
منهم تعرض للاصابات والبعض الاخر استطاع
ان يتم اجلؤه او حتى هو ان ياتي مباشره
الى مقر تواجد السفاره والعلي استضيف سيده
سعوديه كانت متواجده تم اجلاؤها
واستضافتها الان من قبل السفاره السعوديه
في تركيا عارفين باسمك وحدثينا عن الساعات
الحرجه التي عشتها خلال الضرب هذا الزلزال
وضربه للمنطقه التي تتواجدين فيها ايمان
السفياني طبعا جاء الزلزال الساعه 4:00
الفجر احنا كنا نايمين
[موسيقى]
بتعمل ابلاغ عنها بانها موجوده تحت
الانقاب يتم العمل
بالتنسيق بين السلطات السعوديه والتركيه
على البحث عن هذه السيده السعوديه التي
تبلغ من العمر خمسين عام خلال تواجدها في
هذا هذه البنايه وعمليه البحث مستمره عن
هذه السيده عدا ذلك كل السعوديين
والسعوديات تم اجلائهم مباشره وعددهم 45
البعض منهم غادرت غادر هذه المدينه